Organizing a computer desktop is really important...
...and becoming a growing need for most business owners...
...who are doing more and more work on the computer.
The first tip I have for you is don't overcrowd your desktop.
The more icons and shortcuts you have right in front of you,...
...it's going to be harder to find what you need quickly and easily.
The next thing to do is to create shortcuts and folders for frequently used items.
This will help keep you organized and get you to where you need to be quicker.
Third, use a similar filing system for your physical and your electronic files.
Most people are not 100% paperless,...
...so you are probably gonna have a filing system somewhere in your office.
If your electronic system and your physical system mirror each other...
...it will be a lot easier for you to find things offline and on.
Last, do a periodic desktop cleanup.
It can be really easy to add shortcuts, icons and folders to your desktop...
...and you'll end up with the overcrowding problem that we talked about a little earlier.
So every month or six months, depending on the speed at which you add things to your computer,...
...do a periodic cleanup, throw things away,...
...do a little reorganizing to keep things fresh and organized.
We all know that having an organized desktop and workspace...
...is really important as a business owner.
So your virtual desktop should be no exception.